Customs and Border Protection confirms  it is investigating allegations of  sexual assault on a fifteen-year-old  migrant girl by a border officer this  alleged assault first reported by NBC  News took place at a facility in Yuma  Arizona  the teenager from Honduras said the  officer put his hands inside her bra  pulled down her underwear and groped her  during what was supposed to be a routine  pat-down the agency said in a statement  this US Customs and Border Protection  treats those in our custody with dignity  and respect  provides multiple avenues to report any  allegations of misconduct we take all  allegations seriously investigate all  formal complaints now these allegations  come amid reports of unsanitary and  unsafe conditions at overcrowded border  facilities in Texas the agency has asked  for more resources Congress recently  passed 4.6 billion dollars in funding to  ease the crisis